hello everyone I'm here with Dr Jeannie
sinkfield uh thank you so much for
accepting to be interviewed by me uh the
tournament the Karen's cup which I know
it's named after you it's set to start
very soon today and I would like to ask
you a few questions about
um maybe your how did you feel when you
the club in a way decided to name the
tournament after you
oh I kept trying to persuade them they
didn't need to like
we already had a single
do it you know it it was a time we
needed the top women players to be
celebrated
I agree and I'm very appreciative with
that it's great for me as a chess player
and also for the chess fans to see more
female tournaments being played both of
us who are like you know you see the you
know the best men players are actually
the best best players but the women's
tournaments
it is just so much more fun they're
faster and they're Do What I Call things
that you know some of the top players
may not would find too risky but the
women are going we're we're just going
to do this crazy stuff you're going to
get confused if you're running out of
time and I'm going to beat you so I
think I'm just a little bit more fun you
know you so you think
um because you also you know you know to
places I know you're often mentioned the
story about how you introduce uh Rex to
to chess no no no no Rex is playing
Reckless Racing an orphanage you learn
how to play when he was in the orphanage
okay and then he played in high school
and then he played as long as we were
dating and married he's been playing
since he was a little a little boy you
know we start playing a little bit when
we first got married but I decided that
he cared more about it than I do I see
I I thought maybe I misunderstood often
times when you're telling the story that
uh I beat him but that was many many
you're we've been married 50 years and
that was before we got married which
last time I was able to be a kid okay
and now it's now I don't even price okay
well maybe maybe you can take some you
know lessons to surprise him a little
bit with some some opening do you have
an opening to do you like to play
sometimes me I I wrote the booklet learn
your read and write chess yes understand
literacy and that was when I learned
literacy I see so now you know when I
was in my 70s
but I just play a lot of people
worldwide just play for fun
they don't write it down but if you want
to play an autonomous right you want to
replay your games you want to read books
so I thought like
figured out how the literacy I could get
better but there were no booklets yes so
now we got it for those of you out there
they're 13 languages okay I know there
is a language that's not covered okay
and you're a great chess player I need
translators all the people you see
translated
did it for free yes it's a very nice and
took it back to their countries
so this year in in the fall the
Ukrainian Chess Federation is using
Christian Silas translation into
yeah and I'm sorry Romanian Romanian
Romanians are there so many languages
yes in the schools yes so they're going
to have
a booklet the read and write that you
wrote so that a lot a lot of players who
maybe don't have two coaches
if they can learn the literacy
they can run books
and we play their game do you see yes
that is very important and the rich kids
might have coaches the rural kids maybe
not so much
this is just a way of
getting everybody getting everybody to
play and uh everyone is invited to the
kind of game that anyone can play at any
female male any age
as long as you're you know passionate
about the game you can keep keep going
on them now in St Louis there was a pro
football player retired and he was
helping the football teams Denise
Johnson he just passed away he was
requiring every football player to learn
to play chess because he felt that it
taught them how to
conceptualize
their Roots it's very nice that is very
nice Definitely if anyone
speaks one of the languages that does
not have the booklet translated please
do contact the sandwiches club and we'll
try to get it we'll we'll get it
together and translate in another
language and make it accessible to as
many people in the world the latest
languages are Swahili
Armenian
nice very nice Russian tonight there's
Indonesian malays there are lots of lots
of languages hopefully some new ones
will be contacting us I don't know they
just keep showing up you know people get
jealous because so and so I think we're
gonna get Georgia soon okay that would
be very nice I wanna I really appreciate
you joining me for this very short
interview and I want to ask you one last
question about the Karen's cup uh there
are 10 players playing in this
tournament
um you might not be willing to answer
this question but do you have any
favorites
to win this
Well I obviously for the American side
you know Irina would be nice okay so you
just don't know you don't know you don't
you know it's been a little bit of a
while because of the covet and of course
it's been two years of new players that
are brand new that's right and remember
the singfield cup is won by an 18 year
old
[Music]
you know what he did starting at 12. he
listened to all the online video that
the chess club puts out and watched all
the commentary for the game so when he
came here it's like he had been playing
these players for years that's right so
you out there you can
learn from these players maybe one day
unfortunately it in English but you know
but that helps with the language
learning too if you don't speak the
language and you try your best to
understand the chess and kind of listen
to the commentary maybe you get the
chance to learn yeah
listen to yeah
that's right and maybe some of the jokes
don't translate that is true that is
true well I do appreciate you being here
I hope there's gonna be beautiful games
like you're saying attacking games
let's hope let's hope they'll be that
and for future Generations female chess
players who are aspiring to come to this
tournament maybe do something similar as
dalireza was doing follow the live
broadcast try to learn the moves learn
the players and come here in a few years
and try to win the competition there you
go
thank you very much Dr Jeannie I really
appreciate the interview and looking
forward to the event I came to and come
to St Louis just capital of the U.S of
course thank you so much